[Musica]
bentrovate Bentrovati
Allora
connessioni connessioni
intergenerazionali
oggi vi parlerò di questo anzi vi
parleremo di ques perché io lo farò
usando le parole El Lucciola che è mia
figlia che è un'artista con la quale
lavoro abitualmente e lo farà attraverso
delle immagini già Cominciate a vederle
e le connessioni intergenerazionali
sarebbero tutto quello che sta appunto
tra le due frasi che sono state citate
prima Cioè ai miei tempi si stava meglio
o era meglio e Ok
boomer per cercare di colmare la
distanza tra queste due frasi che tutti
avremmo detto ci saremmo sentiti dire su
per
giù non non so bene l'età media ma un
altro titolo che volevo dare era tra
verter e Blanco e poi però mi sono
chiesto verter Immagino su per giù tutti
e lo conosciate o meno però Blanco
magari no allora ho detto che facciamo
un titolo usiamo la parola fake news che
è attuale e e la portiamo a casa facile
per fare questo
viaggio che poi ci porterà a capire se è
corretto parlare di connessioni
intergenerazionali o di disconnessioni
intergenerazionali Io vorrei partire da
un posto non troppo lontano da qui in
Ancona appunto Cioè a casa dei miei
genitori
Learco monina classe
1936 e Angela spalazzi originaria di
Tolentino classe
1937 a casa loro in una casa in cui io
non ho mai abitato perché ci si sono
trasferiti quando io ero già in esilio a
Milano c'è una stanza piena di
fotografie che sono le fotografie della
loro e quindi anche della mia famiglia
si parte dai bisnonni dei miei genit e
si arriva fino alla nipote di mia
sorella quindi si copre un un ventaglio
temporale molto ampio si parte dal
dall'800 e si arriva fino agli anni 10
di di questo millennio in
questa stanza c'è questa fotografia che
potete vedere che mi ha sempre colpito
molto Considerate che ci sono tantissime
foto ma questa fotografia mi ha sempre
colpito perché c'è un signore così a
prima vista anziano che tiene un bambino
con le braghette corte per mano con un
cappotto Allora la prima cosa che m'ha
colpito ai tempi era vedere un bambino
piccolo con i pantaloni corti il
cappotto Perché in genere io che sono
nato nel 9 i pantaloni corti li portavo
d'estate e non d'inverno in questo caso
invece se uno ha il cappotto immagino
sia inverno ma i pantaloni corti
e un tempo funzionava così i pantaloni
corti erano tipici dei piccoli che
quando crescevano a un certo punto si
passava dai pantaloni corti e pantaloni
alla zuava e poi si arrivava a ai
pantaloni lunghi nel frattempo ho visto
che c'è un timer me mi era sfuggito ok
E il Signore elegante siamo per chi è
pratico di Ancona davanti al in Corso
Garibaldi Dalle parti della tazza d'oro
che è un bar storico lo tiene per mano e
e lo guarda
quel signore si chiama Mario quel
bambino si chiama Learco Allora Mario è
mio nonno Learco è mio padre fa
abbastanza sorridere il fatto che io
abbia avuto un nonno che si chiamasse
Mario che all'epoca era il nome più
comune in Italia pare che si chiamasse
Learco credo che solamente quelli nati
nel
1936-37 si chiamassero Learco erano
tutti omaggi a Learco guerra campione di
ciclismo nel caso di mio padre suo
fratello maggiore di 16 anni Enzo aveva
deciso di chiamarlo così proprio perché
era un un fan del ciclismo e del giro
d'Italia in quella foto mio nonno Mario
ha tiene per
mano mio padre e possiamo vedere la mano
destra che è quella che ha tutte le dita
detto così può sembrare come dire una
sottolineatura inutile in realtà questa
foto è circa del 38 e mio nonno di lì a
poco non avrebbe più avuto il pollice
della mano destra questo perché mio mio
nonno nato nel
1897 ha fatto la Prima Guerra Mondiale
negli Arditi nella parte repubblicana
degli Arditi e questa è l'encomio che ha
ricevuto per aver combattuto Vittorio
Veneto
Eh questo fatto essere stato uno degli
Arditi che avevano anche una frangia che
poi era stata in qualche modo vista con
con un certo interesse da parte del del
Fascismo ha fatto sì che quando è
scoppiata la seconda guerra mondiale il
gerarca di Ancona o un gerarca di Ancona
nel senso non so se ce n'erano due e uno
solo è andato da lui gli ha detto Sei
piuttosto grande d'età Ma devi partire
perché sei stato un eroe abbiamo bisogno
di te lui aveva perso il lavoro lavorava
in Ferrovie e aveva perso il lavoro
perché non aveva preso la tessera del
partito era stato quindi licenziato
dalle ferrovie era andato a lavorare al
mattatoio come appunto macellaio quando
il gerarca insistendo lo voleva
costringere a andare a combattere ha
preso la managlia e si ha tagliato il
pollice della mano destra vanificando
l'idea di poter andare in guerra perché
senza pollice opponibile Noi siamo come
insieme alle scimmie gli unici animali
col pollice opponibile non era inutile
andare in guerra sembra un dettaglio
come dire irrilevante ma importante
questo fatto quella foto m'ha molto
colpito sempre per un motivo perché mio
nonno a vederlo così che tiene per mano
Mio padre aveva 41 anni Sembra un uomo
anziano Se voi aveste visto una mia foto
a 41 anni probabilmente avrei avuto i
pantaloni corti i codini gli occhiali
rosa e avrei fatto qualche faccia da
scemo
E immagino anche qualcuno di voi magari
non esattamente tutti questi dettagli
però
diciamo C'era C'era sempre stata negli
ultimi anni una una certa tendenza a
essere giovanili e a sentirsi giovani a
casa di mio nonno che a 41 anni aveva
avuto un figlio Anzi a 39 anni aveva
avuto un figlio immagino un incidente di
percorso visto che aveva un altro figlio
di 16 anni a casa di mio nonno quando io
l'ho conosciuto
negli
anni nel 9 nel 70 ins sono nato nel 9
negli anni in cui ho preso coscienza che
esistesse un
nonno abitavano in una zona di Ancona
che si chiama il piano Il passatempo
preferito di mio nonno e mia nonna era
stare Affacciati alla finestra a
guardare passare le macchine sotto casa
perché per loro le macchine erano una
novità e un'altra caratteristica che
c'era a casa di mio nonno che mi ha
sempre colpito molto c'era una tombola e
di quelle che si si prendevano i i ceci
seccati per coprire le caselle che era
la tombola dei
capelloni Perché Perché negli anni 70 I
capelloni cioè gli Ippi erano qualcosa
di folkloristico e quindi colpivano in
qualche modo l'attenzione di di della
vecchia generazione di quelli che erano
nati nell'800 e nella prima parte del
900 Allora mio nonno era un sign che
sembrava anziano mio padre era un
bambino vestito come un bambino
pantaloni corti
cappottini detto così So che può
sembrare un'ovvietà no gli uomini una
volta si vestivano in maniera elegante
nei giorni di festa Quella era una
fotografia fatta in un giorno di festa e
i bambini si vestivano di bambini
Siccome però io sono partito da a tempi
per
contrapporre da un vissuto personale
Cioè dalla generazione di mio nonno e
alla generazione di mio padre perché
quando si instaura la discussione con
qualcuno di una certa età non anziano
perché io ho 54 anni ma se qualcuno mi
dà dell'anziano gli do una testata in
faccia credo come chiunque di voi però
si sente dire boomer perché ha detto ai
miei tempi di solito se la discussione
Non degenera appunto nessuno parte di
testa eh la conclusione è è sempre stato
così no è sempre stato così Cioè chi
diventa adulto Guarda ai più giovani
dicendo Ah ma voi non sapete fare niente
la musica che ascoltate dico questo
perché di lavoro mi occupo di musica la
musica che ascoltato non funziona tutti
questi ragionamenti Qui non è sempre
stato così non è vero è una
menzogna la gioventù non è sempre
esistita è in qualche modo un'invenzione
del marketing nel
senso La gioventù per per come abbiamo
iniziato a conoscerla è nata verso la
fine del 700 col romanticismo abbiamo
citato prima o citato prima
verter nell'inizio del 900o nei primi
nei primi decenni del 900 c'è stata un
tentativo in qualche modo
di raggrupparli Baden Power ha fatto gli
scout Hitler ha fatto la gioventù
nazista con le debite differenze Ma
negli anni 50 cioè quando mio padre era
un ragazzo cazzo è arrivata la gioventù
E perché è arrivata perché in America
hanno inventato i teenagers hanno
inventato il rock and roll e hanno
deciso che i giovani dovevano diventare
un target di mercato Quindi hanno
iniziato a pensare a colmare dei
desideri che prima non c'erano perché
semplicemente non c'erano i giovani mio
nonno quando aveva 25 anni aveva un
lavoro aveva una moglie aveva una casa
aveva un figlio mio zio Enzo mio padre
quando aveva 25 anni aveva un lavoro
aveva una moglie aveva un figlio mio
fratello Marco e aveva una casa Io
quando avevo 25 anni avevo i capelli
lunghi fino al sedere ho passato
un'intera estate con un paio di
pantaloni del pigiama corti arimo a
suonare musica Punk perché quello era
quello che io pensavo avrei fatto nella
vita in quell'anno ho poi deciso che
avrei fatto altro però diciamo c'è stata
una certa evoluzione o involuzione del
caso in questo lasso di te tempo la
prima volta che io ho sentito parlare di
generazione Visto che stiamo parlando di
generazioni è stato negli anni 90 e è
stato attraverso un libro che si chiama
Generazione X di Douglas kopland che ha
come sottotitolo racconti per una
cultura
accelerata La cosa buffa è che Douglas
kopland che è un uno scrittore e un
artista nato nel
1961 quindi tecnicamente non
appartenente alla generazione X che è
quella che va dal 1965 al 1980 ha reso
famosa una generazione la Generazione X
scrivendone in un romanzo Il romanzo in
cui parlava di
accelerazione lì mi sono incuriosito
come molti e questo è stato un romanzo
di successo e ho scoperto che c'erano
diverse generazioni un tempo le
generazioni erano di circa 25 anni
C'erano i boomer i famosi boomer di cui
io non faccio parte perché sono nato nel
69 che andavano dal 46 al 65 poi c'era
la Generazione X poi c'è stata la
generazione Y che noi conosciamo come
millennials cioè quelli che sono
arrivati al passaggio dei millenni da
maggiorenni Dopodiché dopo i millennials
c'è stata la generazione Z detti anche
zoomer Lucciola che le cui foto state
vedendo è parte della generazione Z poi
c'è stata la generazione Alfa La cosa
buffa è che la generazione Alfa che è da
racchiude i nati dal 2011 in poi è in
questo momento un oggetto di studio di
marketing perché perché appunto la
Generazione X è diventata nota quando
ormai la Generazione X non stava più
agendo se non in età adulta la
generazione alfa è in questo momento
attenzionata da molti mercati io mi
occupo di musica la canzone più
ascoltata al mondo su YouTube con quasi
10 miliardi di streaming è Baby Shark
una canzone che è il corrispettivo
americano di le tagliatelle di nonna
Pina o il coccodrillo come fa 10
miliardi di visualizzazioni tiktok è
diventato il social a cui tutti stanno
guardando e È chiaramente rivolto ai
bambini ai ragazzini La cosa buffa è che
Ovviamente i bambini non erano stati mai
attenzionati dal mercato perché non non
hanno economie non c'hanno uno stipendio
non possono spendere in questo
momento grandissima Attenzione è rivolta
verso di
loro faccio un piccolissimo passo
indietro nel 68 cioè quando non c'erano
i social non c'era internet l'uomo non
era manco andato sulla luna e io non ero
nato quindi Insomma era un mondo
abbastanza mesto e Andy warl aveva detto
che in un futuro non ben identificato
tutti saremmo stati famosi per 15 minuti
oggi l'accelerazione di cui parlava
Douglas Copland Eh i 15 secondi di
tiktok sono diventati già tanto
l'attenzione si dice in rete è tra i 15
e 28 secondi quindi diciamo c'è stata
una velocizzazione estrema Adesso farò
un po' veloce anch'io perché c'ho questo
timer che mi dice che sto andando lungo
eh sempre nel
68 finiva l'esperienza del maestro Manzi
in televisione cioè la lingua italiana
era stata proposta dal maestro Manzi in
Rin con un programma non è mai troppo
tardi che ha contribuito a rendere
l'italiano una lingua parlata chiunque
di voi
eh se oggi ascoltasse una canzone di
Blanco che ho citato prima o di un
trapper faticherebbe a capire cosa sta
dicendo Non solo per una questione di
dizione Ma anche proprio per una
questione di linguaggio perché usa viene
usata una lingua che è una lingua
slang Io quando ero un bambino leggevo
Salgari Salgari era scritto in una
lingua di inizio 900 che io negli anni
70 leggevo senza una traduzione nessuno
me l'aveva tradotto in italiano corrente
perché perché l'italiano fino al maestro
Manzi non era una lingua parlata da un
dalla massa era una lingua parlata nei
Tribunali nei giornali nei in parlamento
e in Senato ma non era una lingua
parlata le canzoni parlavano però quella
lingua lì mio padre ascoltava Modugno e
quel Modugno parlava italiano io più
tardi Ho ascoltato altra musica che era
in italiano in questo momento la musica
parla una lingua che è una lingua
totalmente eh in grado di autoinvitarsi
Cioè
mentre fino a poco tempo fa la lingua
delle canzoni era la lingua che si
parlava quindi è diventata prima l'it
c'era l'italiano standard Poi è
diventato
l'italiano corrente adesso lo slang che
parlano i ragazzi parte dalle canzoni
faccio un esempio quando giovanotti
diceva un du tre casino in una canzone
era strano perché la parola casino non
veniva utilizzata ancora nelle canzoni
ma non se l'è inventata lui lui l'ha
sentita e l'ha messa nelle canzoni oggi
se noi ascoltiamo la musica
Trap Immagino che chiunque di noi
faticherebbe veramente a capire che tipo
di parole vengono pronunciate perché è
una lingua che è stata inventata cosa
stanno facendo Sostanzialmente i giovani
stanno prendendo quella lingua e la
stanno utilizzando per parlarsi tra loro
cioè escludendo in maniera piuttosto
categorica tutti quelli che non siano
parte della loro cerchia è diventato uno
slang un vero e proprio slang e quindi
in qualche modo sono riusciti a fare una
cosa che questo Sì è un punto di
connessione generazionale cioè Hanno
ucciso i padri Ognuno di noi ha tentato
di farlo metaforicamente i miei figli se
l'ascoltano lo fanno anche fisicamente
quindi uccidere i padri fare la
rivoluzione Io adesso potrei anche anche
dire visto che stiamo siamo arrivati in
conclusione che ognuno ha le rivoluzioni
che si merita nel
68 quando io sono stato concepito a
Parigi c'era c'erano le barricate Oggi
c'è da sup che si inventa le sue canzoni
Quindi quando qualcuno vi dirà Ok boomer
voi rispondete Ok boomer un cazzo Fra
ciao
Bra